hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest 24 legends of chess tournament
it's game 4 between vladimir kramnik and
magnus carlsen and
after that loss that we've seen in the
previous video uh we've entered the
final game
uh and uh kramnik is in a must-win
situation uh
he must win this uh game in order to
force armageddon and to
hopefully win the match as he without
winning the match he cannot qualify for
the final of the
legends of chess tournament and magnus
is already qualified but he will of
course
uh uh as best as he can as he usually
does
so kramnik with the white pieces opens
with e4 and magnus goes for c5 i know we
usually say that
you go to for the sicilian when you need
a win but magnus can uh
well go for it whenever he wants and
also probably if he went e5
i don't know if magnus would rather face
uh uh kramnik in
something like the the berlin or or
maybe ryder in the sicilian s kramnik is
well known for his prowess in in the
berlin defense
so here knight to f3 we have d6 and the
d4
uh vlad strikes in the center we have
captures captures knight f6
knight to c3 and now something we don't
see very often from magnus uh
he goes for a6 then neither of sicilian
is on the board
uh and uh usually he of course goes for
this vegetable we've seen him play it
plenty of times but uh now he probably
he's probably
um suspecting that kramnik
has been well prepared for the swedenbc
of course so he decides to mix it up
so here we have bishop the c4 uh
preparing this
uh well well-known maneuver shifting the
bishop to b3
we have b5 by magnus bishop to b3 and
now e6 now we have the
souls in swords and variation on the
border with bishop to e3
uh and the bishop to e7 magnus now
prepares the castle we have queen to e
to end castles
and kramnik still has to decide whether
he wants to play a com king
kong game by castling kingside or will
he go queen side and then
go for the standard uh f3 g4 h4
h5 g5 and so on so here kramnik does go
for f3 and now
he says okay my bishop is nicely placed
here my dark square bishop is
also on a very nice square i'm gonna
play g4 h4 h5
and start an attack against carlson's
king and okay carlson continues
development we have queen to c7
and now g4 uh and okay knight to c6 and
there have been some moves uh played in
this position like queen side castle is
a known move g5 is a known move
uh queen to f2 is a known move but uh
the move
uh the move vladimir plays is a new move
so already as of the knight captures on
c6 uh the move 12 we have a completely
new game
so magnus recaptures we have queen
captures on c6
and now g5 grabbing more space on the
king side preparing h4 h5
and of course g6 so knight has to go
back knight to d7
uh but this is all well known the knight
is coming to the c5
uh with h4 by kramnik and knight to c5
and now
h5 just preparing that g6 move to start
the attack
now as soon as possible so magnus goes
to rook to b8
i just uh p prepares to push on the
queen side and
now g6 by kramnik and now of course you
don't want to capture here
if you capture then ideas like for
example captures captures and knight
d5 come to mind uh sorry not uh not
ah captures right away knight d5 come to
mind uh and then it's just gonna be
very hard for black to play uh as now uh
it's an excellent square for the knight
if you move the queen then you eliminate
the dark square bishop which is a very
strong defender
and of course if you accept the knight
uh just bishop captures attack
attacks the queen and now there's a lot
of pressure here uh the pawn cannot
capture there's this pin
queen h2 followed by queen h7 or h8
is an idea here and black would just
lose terribly
so here after g6 magnus just blocks the
pawn with h6 but
now comes knight to d5 kramnik
goes for this uh uh p sacrifice all the
same
and it's very usual that you will see a
knight d5 sacrifice against the knight
or if it's
uh you know if you are attacking the
knight of you you are most likely to
play knights to d5
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
so let's see how how it works here so
magnus accepts the knight e captures on
d5 we have bishop captures and the queen
to e8 now but now it's a little bit
different as the h file is closed
uh so what happens if you capture if you
capture magnus already grabbed one piece
so he might as well give up the rook for
a second one so let's say characters
captures
and you would get this position where
kramnik would be up a pawn but magnus
would have a bishop and the knight for a
rook which would be
which would be better for black in this
position so after queen to e8
we have uh the move from the thumbnail
uh vladimir continues happily
sacrificing pieces
bishop captures an h6 and now of course
you you really need to capture this it's
not really an option
so magnus uh captures it and now rook
the g1 now preparing uh captures on f7
which will come with a double check from
the pawn and also from the rook and g1
uh so first magnus goes for bishop to h
for check
doesn't allow any queen side castling to
bring the other rook into the game as
well
king to b1 and now queen to e5 here
magnus just says your
your kung fu is weak i don't mind if you
capture here on f7
there's nothing there if you capture
there just king h7 and there is no
attack here these pawns are actually in
black in white's way
and uh you know it probably be better if
they if they weren't
there so maybe if you could get a hold
of this diagonal with the bishop then
maybe
you could be able to do something so
instead we have just
c3 uh kramnik just uh uh he
improves his position here makes an
escape route for the king probably
prepares to bring the other rook into
the game
but now comes bishop to e6 of course now
magnus is a material so he wants to
trade off as many attackers as possible
and now again if you capture here then
kramnik can even
sorry magnus can even start running away
with the king king here and then you
just hide him to safety
uh even ideas like f4 trying to capture
and get rook to f1
uh black can just move the queen and
then let's say captures captures
you don't really have any compensation
here for the sacrifice material so
instead after bishop e6 with
f4 immediately now uh going for captures
captures and then rook to f1
but magnus again says this is this is
nothing he just captures the pawn
and now g captures an f7 with check uh
we have
king to h7 uh it's interesting that if
king captures and rook f1
black is still winning even though you
lose a queen for example king e7
you win the queen but after rook
captures bishop captures king captures
uh black has
still uh so much material for for the
queen and rook
it's two rooks a bishop and the knight
versus a queen uh
and a rook here but this rook still has
a
a long way to go before he actually
enters the game and you know ideas like
rook captures hero are coming so
it's not uh and not at all pleasant for
white so even this would be winning but
instead
magnus just went king to h7 and here uh
it was in this position
on move 24 that vladimir kramnik
resigned the game
and with it the match so here you resign
because you're down too much material
and there's no way to actually continue
the attack like this will get traded off
either black will capture a rifle
capture doesn't really matter
you don't have anything here i like it
uh
there is no way to do anything like you
can do maybe a rook lift rook to g6 but
i mean queen captures on f7 and is just
pointless
nothing is happening here so after this
king to h7 uh
kramnik resigned and magnus carlsen wins
the match which means
magnus won all the matches he played
here uh he won
uh seven of them he won clean but only
two of them against vasily vancouver and
against yani pognishi he had to go into
armageddon but he won both of the
armageddons
and here even though kramer lost the
game and the match we are going
to award him the mr barnes had for his
relentless attack in this game uh as i
think it's the
it's the fair thing to do uh and before
we forget we do have the standings uh
after
uh after this uh
oh sorry layers again uh the standings
after
uh round nine uh from uh the across
table from chess 24 there you have it
uh the players who qualified for the
finals of the legends of chess are
magnus carlsen yanni pomnishi anishigiri
and peter swiddler
and vasily evanchuk missed qualifying by
one point as you can see uh vasily has
13 points and peter swiller has 14
so he almost qualified and then we have
in sixth place vladimir kraunic boris
galifan
being lyra and vishwanathan anand and in
last place uh peter lecko
so there you have it uh that's uh it for
the for the preliminaries of the legends
of chess we are going to continue with
the finals of course
and see who emerges victorious as the
the the true legend of chess
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank frank combs
coin connection pedro quila miranda
amaros mitsuhashi and mila petkovic for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the
legends of chess finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day